is this entertaining every time you
launch into that song i think it's gonna
be a little butterfly no no no john it's
bones by image and dragon oh dang the
best band guys we're gonna watch the
boys season three episode thresh today
last thing we are recording here before
moving
from this nightmare
if you guys can leave a like that'd be
very much appreciated doesn't take too
much work on your end full-length watch
logs where you sync up with the type
code are available for the super sexiest
rejects in the world reaction highlights
and watch alongs included for exclusive
shows as well subscribe and click the
notification bell get notified when our
reaction for the next episode of the
boys is up you'll probably hear some
noise because uh the missus is moving
stuff around right now since we gotta
pack up everything we are recording into
right now tonight as well the boys at
prepper they shop and set it down these
highlights you guys wrong but the real
lastly thank you to storyblocks for
partnering up with us this month as we
have been hiring some more editors and
some new on-screen talent to be here
more regularly working with these brands
is helping to keep us producing more of
these videos and to be trying out some
new things as well so sincerely thank
you let's get to this
[Music]
and don't tense up when you hit the high
it notes it's pain as weakness leaving
the body that's right we do whatever it
takes to win so you go out there and
just keep smiling okay baby
that's it starlight
block that [__] up keep shooting that
body
[Music]
baby baby how was i supposed to know
that something wasn't right yeah
okay
wowie
[Music]
very impressive there is star late
bernie should hire her for her residency
keep me me impotent and obedient like
i'm a [__] puppet
you know what it worked hey ashley
what's crisis management saying about
that i don't know
[Laughter]
poor ashley i am done being persecuted
for my strength samurai mr done being
persecuted for my strength several
videos are persecuted for my strength
persecuted
i do this with our videos this is the
plight of white dudes everywhere
wow what do you mean i'm up
21 points with your base
[Music]
[Laughter]
21 points
they loved your speech a massive 44
uptake with white males in the rust belt
of course
you're saying you're confident and
unapologetic and that you know you're
not afraid to
keep [__] going ashley don't stop
that's got nothing to do with you just
keep going oh jeez
they want me to be myself
and now um
oh no
together you have a q rating of 98
no one's ever been that high
not soldier boy
not anyone look how everyone brings up
soldier boy so much more now you know
they've just started bringing him up all
the time
[Laughter]
that's wrapped like twice lassies
like a bit of power right i got this
feeling in my bunk
look i know what you're going to say no
no and i just wait
i'm just chuffed to have all the boys
back under the same roof right really
i mean there he was right in his fancy
pants
old time he weren't nothing but a soup's
bootleg eh yeah that my son is a
lifetime achievement at the [__] of the
year awards
truly back uh can you please
break my arm
vicky you'll smell it if i fake being
sick so
it's got to be real and
it's gotta last for days
hardcore huey
have a seat please
we've been in three minutes and it's
already the bold and the bad [__]
oh my god
one
two
[Music]
you do know that i have a boyfriend
right love triangles they generate a 47
surge in trending topics on social
platforms let me talk to him first
amazing uh what do you think of our
second choice moonshadow she's body
positive but not too body positive ugh
she's the most qualified well we're
gonna have to run all of this past
homelander of course
actually according to my contract with
mr edgar
i get the final say over the two slots
so why don't you run that password
oh no ashley don't turn on her
did you bring the password
why do you have to leave
i went back to work for little nina i
was moving wait for her and these
[__] [__] boosted him
can you find them they wear masks i
don't know who they were
and i was high
oh
they want to pick you as one of the
winners tonight and you need to say no
why there's something wrong
with homelanders something broken he's
threatened to murder me more than once
he's murdered
oh no
and you're just gonna be putting
yourself and your family in danger
please you need to promise me that you
will leave and you'll never look back
please
i hope you don't snitch on her i'm
afraid he might
i've never been to nicaragua really
because a little birdie told me you were
payback's case officer down there
whatever it is william thinks he may
have heard
he's mistaken
is he
nicaragua's ancient history
not to mention i could be killed just
for telling you and all your agents will
get killed if you don't
would i pick them
reagan's pet project off the books some
of the cash came from selling arms to
iran
oliver north's epic fuck-up
but the rest
um
it was cocaine
i was in charge of trafficking the coke
into the u.s and then using the profits
to buy more weapons
wow
[__] payback
each more ridiculous than the next what
do you say gunpowder give them the
fourth of july let's light them up
please put that down
you know with a figure like yours you
are wasted down here
my humblest apologies
i'm sure this is
disoriented that's ted egger officer
grace mallory isn't it
stanford yeah jeez think of it as a
trial run a trial run from what
superheroes in the military of course
for the first time in over 30 years just
imagine how dumb
[Music]
they belong and that's incredible tell
that's a soldier boy
he's a living breathing american hero
i'm not allowing this i'm sure director
casey will address any concerns you may
have
[Laughter]
fetch water for our tents
thank you so much
he has a pretty good young chunk harlem
yeah he's got the the rhythm and the
sort of erudite cadence
can you please stop eating those in
front of me i'm allergic
so listen oh my god black noir's voice
silent ninja score extremely high with
boys 17 years old the mask lends a
certain mystique [__] mystique
you know if you were a little nicer
maybe you'd find a man
stood out here playing captain lesbo
v24 reactions going through a little
withdrawal there buddy ashley tells me
that you chose silver king k kinkade
i have notes
i have notes i choose the new members
but i am pitching the craziest twist
well i've made my decision oh come on
you haven't even heard it yet
seriously you're gonna love it ready
return of the deal
no
oh you [__] before you say anything
doesn't christ tell us to turn the other
cheek
i need a word
these two chat shall we
absolutely not do you really think i'm
gonna let a muslim in the seven jesus
do i need to remind you of the flight 37
video
release it let's light this candle huh
i mean sure i'll lose everything but
then
i'll have nothing to lose
go ahead partner
do it
come on stan must have thought of
something to fail safe for the
homelander oh yeah
yeah like that oh
no
butcher
are you okay
hear me oh good just gives a minute yeah
do you need any help oh no
don't come in no
uh we have to be as
mean and [__] up as they are no you
sound like butcher i know but annie
he's right he's been right all along i'm
just so
tired
of losing
this is noble
i didn't want to say nothing but i was
trying to show the community i'm down
for the carlos
says when you've been down with any
cause
[Laughter]
i was
terrified luhak came to her rescue the
suspect became aggressive
brother lived a few houses up the street
he was just walking home from work blue
hawk curb stomped him so hard to crack
the pavement oh my goodness
maybe i can throw his family some cash
or something they don't need a handout
they need you to speak up you're in the
[__] seven
yeah but i mean oh dude
nina wants to see you he's guinea how's
your wife
she still enjoys getting herself tossed
by a french man while her husband does
nothing
come on frenchie you take on soups
has it been less than 24 hours
either that or it doesn't work that way
suado went for another joy flight giving
away our position even better the
sandinistas brought russian special
forces with them though that didn't
matter much to the soups
[Music]
god damn it
bunch of idiots
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh man jesus
[Laughter]
got cannibal holocausted
[Music]
[Laughter]
god this team is so frustrated
up the gore this season man
oh
ah
black noir
can't talk no more
oh dude
oh god
thank you soldier boy
do the russians haven't
maybe
wait up where where are you going see
what will i see you again you won't it's
safe for you
oh butcher you said you'd always walked
out for me you promised ryan let go i
won't let you well maybe i don't want to
look at you
after what you've done on my bicker did
you ever think about that oh
no
oh
hit you
[Music]
that's bad
you might have just made things a whole
lot worse sorry if you've gained he goes
a little rough
still a bit bitter you ate his wife's
anus
friend she likes to rim
where is shelley because nobody stole
hair in front of her
she stole it from me
what was your safe word again when i
used the dog collar and the strap on
what was it vincent
just think about my offer
go on scamper away little doggy
damn i don't know if i've ever seen this
actress before oh thanks homelander this
literally means everything to me
[Music]
of course oh you cruel bastard you're
back in the big leagues buddy nothing
but the best for you
he only gave him a plate
christ
you know who i've been reading up on
lately dr martin luther king
well my relationship with king is
deepened of light
of course it has so villainized
persecuted
spoke
my god
i mean they [__] love me
there's always been so so many things i
want to do and now i can do them all
finally
oh no ugh
what's for you big guy me
specialty
it is a south korean delicacy
you knew it oh damn it
oh my god
it's tim
he's my friend i uh
i can't eat them i'm not going to eat
them oh yes
[Music]
yes
hey deep
what
eat [__] timothy
oh
oh buddy no
i'm so sorry
he's gonna puke wasn't that delicious
god damn that was so mean set up a mean
with you me
and then nina not no this is a very it's
a very bad idea no frenchie it's a very
[__] good idea
we miss you
and what are we doing this for good dog
because my son
we're going to russia
there we go
that lines up i told him i was thrilled
to join the team no alex alex that's
that's a mistake i was in rehab but you
didn't leave do you really think i'm
gonna bail on you now i'm an [__] but
i'm not that much of an [__] kiss him
yeah it's gonna happen at some point
no
the others don't get it but i do
if there's
anything that i've learned
[Laughter]
thank you
final new member of the seven is
the seventh sees the deep
ugh
well frankly i'm moved and inspired that
starlight here has chosen to forgive you
i accept your apology deep
you deserve a second chance thank you
starlight
thank you sterling you keep your
distance pal because uh well she's my
girl now
[Music]
i'm sorry i i can't keep it a secret
anymore no no no
no
hashtag
homelight
cut huh incredible god [__] play
[Music]
yeah let's uh let's go again okay one
more do it again great
starlight and i are in love
[Music]
[Applause]
all the pain
fascinating booking
oh that's so cruel
that's just the number one thing
hopelander knows how to do is just find
the cruelest possible thing
oh and surprise i'd surprise you with
this
how does that come at all
oh
i have
nipple chills but
not the good cops dreadful nipple juice
the most sinister nipple gels
nipple shivers
yeah that don't mess me up
that poor woman
that poor real life woman yes
justice for any january
yeah
oh that's that's sick
so sick
disgusting
but hey
everything's good with the deep so
yeah
it's good
all right let's talk about it
well
hey to check out this word from our
sponsor today storybooks best sponsor
love them yep let's slide in the mood a
tad bit for just
yeah thank you for sponsoring this video
thank you to storyblocks for sponsoring
this video being the cinematic artisans
we obviously are we are always in search
of ways to make our videos look better
faster and most of all for cheap cheap
is good and if you're a content creator
or filmmaker or anything in between
you're probably in a similar position
it's tough to get your content looking
as good as it can be without breaking
the bank or burning yourself out in the
process which is why i heavily encourage
you guys to check out what storyblocks
has to offer cheap is good do you feel
like this is their way of telling us
that the videos could be looking better
yes whether it's the credibility of an
exotic establishing shot the soothing
comfort of the perfect music bed or just
the satisfaction of increasing your
graphical capability storybox has an
incredibly inclusive and diverse library
of faces places sounds titles
transitions filters and effects and more
over a million assets royalty free and
available for personal and commercial
use with your membership sounds so
affordable this is quite affordable they
have multiple subscription levels to
suit your exact needs whether you're an
independent indie solo creator or a
whole team so if you want to learn more
head on down to our link in the
description box and get started that's
at storyblocks.com
rejects now back to the video
anyway
yeah that won't put me in a mood
i can uh why how
what mood
i feel affected by it the other ones
have left me more like um jazzed
and uh this one is uh
it's really interesting when you when
you do the comparison of the release of
season two and season three with the
three episodes yeah
where
season two was like
building building crazy yeah
when it gets there it's worth it and
then this was like crazy crazy and
this is starts off crazy and and then oh
wow this is just really dark and
uncomfortable it starts crazy and that
de-escalates into what's true the rim
underneath badassness
i like it i like it i i wouldn't have it
any other way to be honest it is so
unsettling and
and uh it it it
it's unnerving in a way that is so it's
uncomfortable yes uncomfortable is like
the most simple word i could find but
it's so true
because everything they're doing with
the with these characters is because
this was more like this more somber
moments they had more dramatic moments
while even even when you're seeing
payback in
uh
where were they corrupt
yeah when you're seeing payback they're
in the reagan time
and
there i thought it might be like oh
wacky you know we're seeing this
some characters feel like spoof of the
avengers you know so obviously with
soldier boy
and being like the captain america suado
kind of sort of reminded you of that man
had a feeling it would be a little bit
more of that that sues the suicide squad
that's kind of like a superhero thing to
do now is introduce a team and kill off
a bunch of them yeah
you know all kind of dopey characters
and then yeah you watch them die
terribly yeah but even like a recent
movie and i won't say just in case
people haven't seen it but even in a
recent movie in a recent stuff happening
how many recent comic movies are there
you probably you know what i'm talking
about early june so just think back
uh yeah so even that it's kind of a
superhero thing to do although it's not
like surprising here just because of the
fact that payback isn't a
prevalent team uh at the moment but
but seeing the
the
the harrowing stuff that
mallory went through that it wasn't that
she's just some traitor that she was
taking advantage of and used in this
situation
and experienced so much suffering and
loss from it and she has her core memory
for why she goes after supes and why she
hates bot
so much
and uh
and then everything with even a train
you know
by possibly going down the path of
actually caring about the community
actually caring about black people in a
way and caring about their suffrage
instead of just oh i could capitalize
off of the pain of black culture and use
it as a way to lift myself up and be
back in the seven as like top dog but
really no that's not the case
and now here he's being witnessed that
you see him being affected by a real
uh element of real world crime that
occurs
and of course uh you know
it is a fascinating bookend with
starlight to show her back with her mom
of what stage mom being used and how she
the clenching of the fist is a yeah act
of us like
directing the pain
or kind of harm it's not really harming
yourself but it can be if you go too
hard you could like if you have long
nails you can harm yourself but it is
like um directing the pain and now
to be back here where she's just
becoming so closed off again where
she thought this would be her season as
well where everything would be good
and now it's
worse than before
you know it's back to being taken
advantage of so
yeah this was even with the deep i felt
bad for him i gotta admit like deep's
not a character i often feel bad for you
someone was going to just pity but
killing uh killing timothy that was
messed up that was really messed up
i'm an animal lover so that really
really bothered me i don't care about
animals so i thought that scene was
hilarious hilarious eating get [__]
yeah what's the big deal it's just food
you hear a coward what's the difference
fish come on man climb that corporate
ladder
[Music]
no i absolutely agree this has been a
fascinating turn because yeah we've sat
here and said you know each of these
feels like its own kind of centered
episode and it doesn't need like you
know the other episodes around it to
feel complete or like a complete start
although this first
chunk
as of this episode does kind of solidify
something over the three even though
they do feel more independent than
season two's kickoff episodes
yeah by this point you get the full
setting of the place that homelander is
under
like just ex every time there's just
exponentially fewer controls and
safeguards on him and and that's
something that each you know each season
they're pretty good at developing these
stakes where i'm like
this could be like devastating to the
entire world and how are they going to
figure this out
and also top this or you know come up
with something just as engaging next
season and i appreciate that they don't
pull punches that way so yeah with
homelander especially as of this third
episode you're sitting here going like
man he he really can't do like whatever
he wants and unless they find this
weapon but i have to imagine it's not
going to
ultimately come down to the weapon in
the way that we expect like it really
does feel hopeless as of this moment
this episode specifically and two you
feel just the depth
of depravity that propping all this
stuff up requires and i feel like this
episode being the one where huey and
it's been interesting to watch his turn
as well basically sort of surrendering
to the idea of look yeah i tried to do
it legit and even the legit way is
filled with secrets and lies and and
horrific circumstances so starlight can
you please just soldier through this
and like it's really heartbreaking to
watch that at the end because you know
that there are so many overlapping
contexts and you've got super sonic and
you're like well maybe he will at least
be an ally to her during this situation
i could also really understand though
how he could get suckered into this
whole you know dog and pony show that is
the seven and that is vaught and that
yeah just perpetuates this ever twisting
just you know and spiral into the depths
of
awful human behavior and so yeah it's
like everything starlight does from here
on out seems like it's just going to be
trauma
and uh
yeah to like center back in on that like
the way that he has invaded and that he
the homelander like overtly
uh
just
like sadistically
exerts his control and authority over
people is like is really unnerving
especially when you think that yeah this
is a really heightened caricature of
various modes of pop culture and various
aspects of society but at the same time
especially in recent years of what we've
learned is possible out there in the
corporate and uh socio-economic
political worlds
you know it also feels like it's echoing
something true and and disgusting and i
mean you know it's we're watching this
not not that there are super
direct parallels but it's like it's
funny to watch this while there's like a
major
uh you know abuse and defamation trial
happening in popular culture because
then you have examples of how those
things happen how they happen in
entertainment scenarios and how they
happen with these giant
marketing apparatuses surrounding them
to sculpt the truth like yeah it's nice
because you've got all the cool
superhero you know uh edgy [__] but then
you can think about stuff like that and
that's kind of the impression this
episode left on me is that
you know
yeah
it's cruel stuff
i think this one this episode was
showing that everyone's just giving in
to their darkness this time around like
everyone is succumbing to
the darkest parts of themselves and the
most desperate
yes and and and in many ways yeah
it's
for some people the most desperate and
other ones like like homelander there's
nothing desperate about it to him
with him he's just
he i i
i think it's a commentary on trumpism
and in many ways
uh like there's other types of
personalities but again knowing
who this show is developed by the
producers involved and how spoken they
are
a lot of the commentary of
of this guy of you know i want to be
loved and if i can't be loved i will
gladly be feared and i will ruin your
life
is
just so diabolical
which is a big theme with some of these
characters diabolical usually being like
oh so fun and messed up this is
this is uh psychologically messed up
butcher
succumbing to his own darkness when he
was on a path of
filling himself with more light you know
he reached a breaking point but then he
rejects ryan and hurts him
and you could tell how tortured he is by
such a decision
but he gave into his darkness he was
giving into his darkness starlight's
giving it to her darkness everyone is
giving it to their darkness frenchy
um
coming to terms with
he's not a leader
and
he is
often used as you know as the woman put
it like a dog
you know who just always needs someone
to take orders from and work for
and even then you see
that moment where when he's talking to a
butcher
and he says no and he's can we see how
how with the scene beforehand how he
wants nothing to do with this woman and
it hates this whole possibility of
going back to her and stuff and it took
took him some balls to stand up to her
and then butcher pushes just a tiny bit
and you can see butcher's putting his
foot down for it
and he gives in everyone's just giving
in
it's it's
this was a really
dark episode to me this was a very very
dark episode the deep even like eating
his own friend
yeah the whole thing with his wife
well his wife
yeah celebrity wife
goddamn
opportunist wife
and good i i like the casting too for
young malory and young uh
uh stan edgar too
i thought stan edgar felt like an
impression
yeah like a
like a solid impression but also too
like i'm not a lot i'm more focused on
like this is not a bad impression yeah
but uh especially the one who played
grace mallory i thought she did a
terrific job and did a lot to humanize
her experience
poor ryan
i really liked what they were doing i
was really happy about
that was an unexpected dynamic that the
trailers didn't even lead on is
something that this show would be doing
with them getting along like that's
heartbreaking
i've never quite been heartbroken with
this show yeah as much as i love it
there's some things here that like
really hurt well because with ryan i
think that's great because you have
such a thin line like you could see how
just a couple of the right traumatic
moments could
you know
warp this kid not to the same degree as
a homelander but in a way that is sort
of unmitigated and volatile yeah and
could get to there because you obviously
of who his dad is
uh and so yeah i feel like it's
heartbreaking
and there's just bigger stakes because
it's like if anybody needs to be looked
out for and and you know nurtured the
right way it's it's probably this kids
well they do a lot of in this show of
viewing the world through media yep yeah
you know they often even at the
beginning of this episode there's those
sequences where people are watching
the world unfold through television you
know controlling the media media
propaganda a lot of the time
and
you think about a character like ryan
who is
who did accidentally murder his own mom
and
who is the dad is celebrated as this
glorious hero yeah super loved
he knows the truth that he is
villainous and vile
and then you get rejected by surrogate
father
and surrogate father leaves you saying
what you did to your mom it's like you
to me that's scary like wow i butchered
you know if you wanted to leave him
fine
i mean not fine but
don't push the kid down a path that
could eventually snowball him
same as telling your dog to leave yeah
in some old movie
yeah that's that to me was very that was
very um
i was like that was not a smart choice
yeah it was that was like that could
lead to some terrible consequences yeah
when they're standing by the window and
he's like i feel so bad i'm like maybe
you could have chosen a different way to
do the same thing you just did without
and i know that part of that is a snap
in the moment but it's also like
i i need to separate myself from you
because of all this danger you know
it is interesting what they're unpacking
and i wish that
i kind of wish the trailers didn't show
us the jets and necklaces
yeah he's being stored somewhere for
resurrection in modern day time yeah
it would be nice to just have it be a
surprise like oh he's playing him in the
flashbacks cool cool good to know
it's nice to have him here but i won't
get too you know uh attached or or you
know intent on yeah a certain version of
this
yeah i i think this i think what this is
showing is like we always know that
there's the
the line that homeowner could cross to
being
uh the person who commits mass genocide
we we know that he could he's capable of
that
like the way he flips that conversation
with starlight
like the last season ended with the
leverage
of you will not be loved
you know they had the crowd noise of him
thinking a bunch of people are chanting
homeland or that's the thing he lives
for he wants to be loved
and
you know he goes yeah but if i
you he if he has nothing to lose then
screw it it's just just world domination
global domination global destruction
and i keep thinking like there's got to
be something that they developed
as a fail safe to take him out there has
to be something along the way that they
developed where
worst case if we a [__] because like
stan anger shows no fear towards him
yeah
and sometimes i go are you sure you want
to be that way around him because yeah
what do you got man
what what true leverage especially now
what do you have and i almost wonder if
this season might set up for a stan egg
or death well i think he likes to watch
people suffer in all kinds of ways it
doesn't matter what it is but that's
what he gets off on that
more than anything else is watching
people suffer
uh like inviting the deep back in as a
way to make starlight suffer but then to
also torture the deep
is
is so
such a safest feeling he's such a sick
guy
and uh he's always got to reinforce his
control
by by breaking the people around him and
you know in that speech he's giving him
like i could do whatever i want and
people will love me like that's the key
and
i don't
know
it's like he forgot some things he did
last season then
or he's just not going to care about a
certain demographic
yeah he's not going to care about them
you know like oh your points dropped
these urban communities
but this community really loves you so
i'm just going to lean into that
where and because in last season there
were the people were protesting against
like even this season starts off because
of things he did yeah yeah you know
um but there is a group out there that
really
depending on how he
how he handles his composure and
confidence
around situations that that's the thing
is like
if if you are someone who can proceed
with like no [__] given you're just
gonna be
a really
strong and you're just gonna be
confident in what you're doing i'm not
wrong i'm not gonna apologize for [__]
yeah
you will attract an audience
and who doesn't people love people who
tell it like it is but when you try to
be apologetic or try to spin into
something else people you know
get mad at
the fact that they feel there's they're
looking at a lie they're looking at a
mask yeah you know weakness yeah
where it's like if you just show who you
are underneath you will find the people
because at the end of the day there's
always this level of
some type of whether it's
good or bad if you're
there's something about honesty that's
appealing yeah
um
well yeah i'd follow homelander
that's good
yeah it's the depths of this world
into the depths of depravity and beyond
i do it
no matter what you have to eat no well
you know even with huey though like
telling her telling starlight you know
at least as honest with her as opposed
to bullshitting her about stuff
but even telling her like yeah you gotta
suffer and i'm putting your life
on on edge entirely
yeah you're at risk at every moment now
because we have a cause we gotta fulfill
oh
you're gonna lose her man
i think one way or the other they can't
they can't that's the rule of romantic
couples in these kinds of shows can't
stay together forever what's super
sonic's power
you know
they they talked about it
can he get can he get does he have like
supersonic speed abilities
agility or is it like some kind of wave
projection i know they did that american
hero you know in the show
that they're doing here they did some
obstacle course bit but it was very
brief
and the rest of the time he's just
behind the scenes on the show we're
dancing yeah yeah we'll see it we'll see
i mean we'll i imagine now that he's
part of the seven we'll see him do some
stuff yeah out in the field
i wonder how that character's gonna get
a twist too because they've developed
him thus far as a pretty upstanding
person and they talk in this episode
about like you know i was an addict and
i had all this recovery to do and it
seems like he's really done it but also
i know that you know you got a character
like homelander if he gets even a whiff
of that history he's gonna
you know
use that to his advantage so i'm very
worried for that character because he
seems so wholesome right now especially
with everything they've had like all the
opportunities he's had to be skeevy
about the starlight and huey business
and all that stuff but
yeah this was this is maddening in a lot
of ways this episode
maddening and soul crushing
all right
well we're done thanks for being here
we'll
see you guys soon
[Music]